and the Atlanta Journal Constitution
reports the NSA contract accused of
leaking government secrets was denied
bond
prosecutors say reality ly winner wrote
in a notebook about how she wanted to
burn down the White House the government
argues she caused exceptionally grave
damage to national security when she
allegedly passed a classified document
to a news outlet David Beck no is an
Augusta Georgia outside the United
States District Courthouse David good
morning Charlie good morning it is
possible reality winner may face even
more charges and here's part of the
reason why yesterday as we were in court
we heard the government say that reality
winner had a conversation with her mom
from jail and it was recorded and in the
call she said mom I got arrested for
those documents which led the government
to wonder what else does she have that
we don't even know about the
government's lawyers say they're
concerned that former Air Force linguist
reality ly winner may have stolen her
exposed other state secrets while
assistant US attorney Jennifer Salah
recalled winner extremely intelligent
she said the government's evidence
against her is downright frightening the
Department of Justice says the NSA
contractor has admitted to taking a
top-secret intelligence document from
her employer which details hacking by
the Russian military intelligence inside
her Augusta Georgia home agency's
computers for cellphones and three guns
including an ar-15
they also found handwritten notes
including one where she allegedly said I
want to burn the White House down
prosecutors now allege that winter
plugged an external hard drive into a
top-secret Air Force computer but
authorities don't know where that drive
is located winner has pleaded not guilty
in the Trump administration's first
criminal leak case her defense attorney
Titus Nichols argued the government is
scraping and clawing to build a mountain
out of a molehill but prosecutors say in
recorded jail house calls winner told
her sister she would quote played a
pretty white cute card
winners mother and stepfather testified
on her behalf
any response Billie Jean winner Davis
did not want to talk after court but she
testified her daughter was a top student
who taught herself Arabic when she was
17
the couple had previously spoken to CBS
this morning when she sees something
wrong she goes to write it when
she sees a need she goes to to film it
she goes to fix things she's a good
person I know that if she did do
something wrong
she's will she's ready to face the
consequences and she will
so in denying her bail the judge said he
was concerned about reality winners
alleged fascination with the Middle East
and her desire to meet with Taliban a
leadership Gail this was also
interesting she apparently had a phone
call with her mother from jail again it
was recorded where she allegedly said
hey mom played the angle that I feared
for my life when I got arrested and then
she allegedly said if I don't get bail
go nuclear with the press Wow David that
is interesting and as always you tell it
very well thank you very much